Hả các chiến năm nay không thì sự đôi.
Bịyểm cao và muốn đôi hậu tốt đồ chưa chắc đường đầu,
phụy hưu qua tế người sẹp từ viên cho hai các chiến,
và nhận lắm của điều rằng đó là vào các năm kì xyu.
Năm các bạn sinh ra hay.
Hãy đến nước Việt Nam được các bạn sản sinh ra hay phởi bà mấy mốt chượng chế em.
Để giờ, số đứng chế em này rất đôi, phó gà đứa 2 gà bà,
đôi cho hai các bạn.
Tất cả chưa đi tì thôi, các bạn có một cái lượng học xin,
đi tìm của lượng học xin cạnh tranh, các bạn có một học phút của lưỡng rồi.
Đây là một trong những điều mà khiến rất nhiều học xin,
mà hiện tàn kè cả các bạn có một cuộc hóa lưỡng lượng nào,
cũng chưa chắc đau đường vào cạnh cười này, hậu mà mấy đồ nhạc.
Và những các bạn biết rồi, cuộc xơi của những sự đau là cuộc xơi của những số lượng rất là hiểu hạn thôi.
Năm nay các bạn có số lượng học xin thang ra,
rất trám là thang ra, gí có kí đau nổi.
Gấp lối xói mọi năm,
tên là cơ hội của mối 1 bằng bông yên dạm,
đi một lượng,
hậu mà anh,
bình thường mối trường nào khiến lấy một lượng chỉ tiêu tiêu nên đình thôi.
Hó không thể đẹp,
em chương không thể đẹp,
thêm lấp,
không thể đẹp,
em giao phía để dạy các bạn được.
Bây giờ,
nhưng số lượng học xin và số lượng tí xin thang dự,
là thang công đôi,
điều này tạm lên một áp lượng của gú của lượng dạy cho hai gà chiến,
kè cả các bạn có rất rất sớm,
kè cả các bạn có rất hỗng lượng học tập biêm cao,
nhưng mà chưa thắc của anh đôi được này học,
bởi vì số dạy học xin năm nay tí gì là khoá khủy phim,
sẽ thay con trước kể là những lượng học xin mà các bạn,
để xích tự gó đồ,
năm 1 rồi các bạn để phung cao làm các bạn quay trả lại.
Tham gia của mối các bạn,
đứa xa,
đây là,
cửa sự đây là một năm học rất không liệt,
để cho hai gà chiến,
tắc biệt là người đứng bà nào để tạy còn chưa chứa xin xuất phát sớm,
để xa,
rất là hội muốn còn li của thầy,
cân đừng có mối lột xin học tập,
và còn những phung phát là bạn để cụ thề,
thì hẹn tà cho lo viết thì thích thánh năng dậy cho các bạn để cực kỷ chiến điên,
của những phương phát này.
Và nếu như hẹn tà,
hai gà chiến còn chưa chứa xin xuất phát sớm,
thì em gần như không có câu đồ được hả mà mày đâu.
Con hai gà chiến đặc sức phát rồi,
mình chưa luôn trường học tập,
nhẳng tình chức tiếp về quan phái,
thì nó thành chăm biên.
Ởa, hòa là,
sự là phù liệt chứ tiếp từ bánh cho các bạn,